for the next hour a conversation with
the two co-authors of the Washington
Post book titled Trump revealed an
American journey of ambition ego money
and power and joining us here at the
table is Mark Fisher and michael kranish
gentlemen thank you both very much for
being with us
michael kranish let me begin with you
what kind of reaction did you get from
Donald Trump well for this book Trump
was very gracious and generous with his
time he spent about 20 hours with a team
of Washington Post reporters doing
interviews the day before the book came
out this week he tweeted don't buy the
book it's boring
he can't have read it because he we
didn't set him on the Vans copy we
haven't heard anything else directly
from him but it is a we hope an
even-handed book and that people will
see as a thorough biography of him mark
Fisher let me begin where you begin in
the book which is his life story and it
is a full accounting of his life you
said he knew how to be famous he knew
how to win numbers to get ratings to
make people take notice
he made a lifelong study of how to
create buzz glitz you write was one
level up from flash can you explain he
has this hierarchy of the kind of buzz
and reaction that he can get from the
media and he's made a lifelong study of
manipulating the media of using the
media and he learned at a very early age
from his mentor of the New York lawyer
Roy Cohn that all publicity is good
publicity and he genuinely believes that
getting his name out there in all these
different ways throughout his entire
life from being seen with the prettiest
models and celebrities at Studio 54 back
in the 70s and 80s all the way up to his
rallies today with lots of stops in
between on Saturday Night Live and
WrestleMania and all of that stuff and
what he did with that was he built this
idea of Trump as not just a person but a
brand an image someone that people could
aspire to be like a symbol of American
success and wealth and he did this very
thoughtfully and he did it while
thinking of himself as kind of a
provocateur of a man of the people he
that likes to think of himself as
michael kranish you write just as he did
at school Donald Trump rebelled against
the rules arguing with his father
nonetheless Fred his father always told
his son that he was quote a king and he
needed to become a killer in
thing he did well you know his father
Fred Trump who was a great builder in
New York before Donald Trump was and
then brought Donald into his company he
was given the Horatio Alger award which
is the award for coming up from modest
means and becoming a big success and
what Fred told his father was that you
have to work on something that you love
otherwise you'll be a nothing quote
unquote so Fred imbue this philosophy
into Donald that you really have to be
something in something big so throughout
his life
Trump's tried to live up to his father's
admonition to to be something big and so
mark Fisher that explains this next
paragraph from your book though a
creature of his father's business and a
beneficiary of a Donald yearn for
something more his father's
outer-borough Empire in Queens in Donald
Trump writing it was not a world I found
very attractive so talk a little bit
about that yeah so in Fred Trump was a
very successful builder but he didn't
middle-class housing in Brooklyn and
Queens the outer boroughs of New York
City and Donald Trump thought of this as
just not reaching for them for the sky
not not reaching for the upper echelon
of society and of business Donald Trump
was enraptured with the idea of crossing
the bridge into Manhattan going into the
the toughest real estate market in the
country and being around all the wealthy
people and the high society types he
wanted the challenge of taking on that
world and being a part of that world and
so he liked he loved his father and he
loved what his father taught him about
the business but he wanted something
more and he thought of his father as not
quite having the killer instinct the
ambition that Donald Trump really wanted
and that Donald Trump found in that
mentor Roy Cohn and in that exciting
Society of Manhattan in the 1970s and
80s and his dad did not quite understand
that early on correct his dad had this
philosophy of you know we're gonna build
steady we're gonna do things as cheaply
as possible and we're gonna have a
steady market and he advised his son not
to go to Manhattan and his son did go to
Manhattan went to Atlantic City he
advised his son don't go deeply into
debt and his son proudly proclaimed that
he was the king of debts so he did
follow his father into the business but
in a very different direction
who was Roy Cohn well this is a
foundational story for Donald Trump
Donald Trump and his father Fred Trump
Trump management company in Brooklyn and
Queens their office was a modest place
near Coney Island and they had thousands
of apartments that they rented so one
day the federal government sued Donald
Trump and Fred Trump for racial bias
saying they weren't renting to blacks
and Donald Trump had to decide do I
settle this case or do I fight the
federal government and he met Roy Cohn
who was the lawyer who famously was at
Joe McCarthy's side during the are
McCarthy hearings here in DC and Roy
Cohn advised Donald Trump
don't settle fight the government fight
like hell and when they hit you hit back
ten times harder so Roy Cohn was a very
important advisor in Donald Trump's life
they eventually did settle that suit
against the federal government but it
was very important to understand Donald
Trump's arc that he kept this philosophy
of one year hit hit back ten times
harder
two more excerpts from the book and then
we'll get to your calls and comments
with our two guests Marc Fisher and
michael kranish you're right Donald
Trump built his reputation selling real
estate but the thing he had always
wanted to sell was Donald Trump his
career with NBC's The Apprentice would
finally make Trump into a household
brand this was a really interesting
transformation that we trace and Trump
revealed from that real estate developer
role building buildings in New York City
and in other places around the country
to realizing that he didn't need to put
up his own money he didn't need to
finance his projects he actually could
make a lot of money simply by selling
franchising his name and so in recent
years many if not most of his projects
both in the United States and around the
world have been cases in which Donald
Trump has literally rented out his name
for a guaranteed annual income of a
healthy income that he received whether
those projects succeeded or not there
are stories that we tell in the book we
sent reporters to places like Kazakhstan
and Panama to look at some of the Trump
projects that really aren't Trump
projects other people put up the money
other people created these buildings
hotels golf courses those kinds of
things and Donald Trump rents his name
and even if the building doesn't get off
the ground or completely flops he has a
guaranteed stream of income much more
secure than the kind of risk
developer takes as he did earlier in his
career Emeco cranny she write about the
letter that Donald Trump received from a
former president Richard Nixon how Pat
Nixon had eyed him as a potential
politician about his visit to New
Hampshire in the late 1980s when he was
talked about by some in the state to run
for president and then you write quote
in 1987 Trump declined the Democrats
invitation to raise money prominent
Republicans continued to court him as a
donor or a future candidate Trump
reveled in the curiosity about his
ambitions an emerging political profile
that's right
you know chapter 16 in the book is
titled political chameleon so maybe
that's a provocative title but the
reason we wrote that is because it's
clearly documented in the book Donald
Trump changed party affiliation seven
times Democrat Republican independent of
Reform Party fact the Republican he
changed positions many times during his
career of abortion immigration taxes
other matters because Donald Trump
really hasn't seen himself as a member
of one party or the other he see himself
as a business person who has tried to
court politicians who would be helpful
for him and getting tax breaks and other
matters so he's seen himself throughout
his career as an outsider what that's
meant is that he has not been on on a
uniform track he's often changed his
view and his party and politics you know
according to the moment we asked him
about this we were in Trump Tower and
one of our interview sessions and I
asked mr. Trump what do you say to
potential voters who say what are your
core beliefs since you've changed your
party and positions so many times and
unlike a lot of other politicians that
I've interviewed he didn't push back and
pound his desk but with his fist and say
you know of course I have these core
beliefs instead it was well I was a
business person and I needed friends for
what I was doing and then that's the way
I viewed it I wanted to keep these folks
as my friends I want to share with you
this is an interview we did a very brief
interview with Donald Trump back in
February of this year in New Hampshire
on the weekend before the New Hampshire
primary and he mentioned your sit-down
interviews with Donald Trump just want
to share with you what we saw but we're
going to change and renegotiate our
trade
and right there you're talking about
tremendous numbers of hundreds of
billions of dollars and with that I have
thousands of people back here and I have
to go real quickly though let me I said
what was your father feel about this
when he expected to be running for
president I think it'd be very proud my
father was a great guy and he always had
a lot of confidence in me and I think
he'd be very real and finally what does
this experience been like for you
personally it's been amazing I hope you
like to debate less
but it's been amazing it's been an
incredible experience and I've always
been a businessman and a builder and a
jobs producer it's been amazing are you
willing to
what it takes to win oh yeah absolutely
have you been in the White House before
mr. Jordan how harbor's times 25 how
would you change Washington that's a
very big question want to have all these
people let me tell you I'll change it by
getting the greatest people in this
country and that's the greatest people
in the world to help me run the country
so Marc Fisher showed that interview
because it just gives you a sense of how
he is focused not only on the questions
but also the crowd waiting for him and
kept referring to that during the course
of what was essentially a five-minute
conversation he has an uncanny knack for
reading a crowd and the genius of his
performance in the primary season was
his ability to connect with people in
those live settings he feeds off the
crowd he obviously has a big ego anyone
for or against him would agree on that
but he it's fed by those crowds and that
he gets he's absolutely buoyed by that
it's it's kind of awkward sometimes to
see him in these more constricted
settings I like reading off a
teleprompter he doesn't look comfortable
there Donald Trump truly believes that
he is best when he's going from his gut
is instinct he's not much of a reader
he's not one to studies issues
he's very skeptical of things like
reports and briefings he says that he
wants to learn about issues by hearing a
quick summary from someone and then
making his own decision on the spot from
his gut Marc Fisher who is senior editor
for The Washington Post and michael
kranish who is a national political
investigative reporter and part of a
team that has put together this new book
Trump revealed now into your calls and
comments kasia's joining us from Grand
Junction Colorado good morning good
morning and thank you became a call I
had a couple of things first off I think
that our nation as a whole should take a
strong look at what they do in the apps
on a computer that we should update
capitalistic government to something
that fits us more in those like the
Space Age maybe you like say I find it
to be a terribly cold calculating
everything's got it surprise type of I
always have and within that you have
people limiting a president to a total
of eight years to you know get elected
get used to the country have them get
used to him or her and then start these
different programs which the President
Obama didn't and with a great skill by
the way I'm a big fan is and but then at
the end eight years you know the Obama
care does have some glitches it had some
problems that it needs to work out now
he can't do that if he's kicked out you
know after eight years you need time to
be able to put those into practice and
say well this works that doesn't and
throw out what doesn't work and add
something that does so you're saying
it's time to change the constitution to
let a president maybe serve a third term
I mean what do we do if we're not
changing we're David Cassie thank you
for the call well let me take her point
one step further Donald Trump says that
he is going to fundamentally change
Washington we've heard that from past
presidents Jimmy Carter Ronald Reagan
Bill Clinton Barack Obama well you know
Washington is broken most people would
say this this cyber what a series a
couple of years ago we called it at the
mouth of the Boston Globe called a
broken city in the nation is divided so
I think a lot of people are looking for
an outsider to come in and change things
the the thing is is that you don't do it
by yourself as by executive Fiat you
need the cooperation of Congress here's
a man who was obviously not liked by
Democrats and does not like liked by a
lot of members of his own Republican
Party so he calls himself a deal maker
but he has clearly turned off a number
of people he would need to make deals
with including the Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan so to get things done he needs
to work with those folks so that remains
to be seen whether he could truly
accomplish that he would need a big
victory in order to have a mandate to
come in and be able to change things as
he wants to this is a to photographs
Ivanka Trump his first wife and Marla
maples his second wife he reportedly has
said that he was bored with his second
wife when she was walking down the aisle
Marla maples
and you right quote at 58
two failed marriages Trump appeared to
have found a partner who fulfilled his
long-standing desire for a no
maintenance woman who did not generate
headlines or seek to upstage him Donald
Trump especially with his first wife
Ivana had someone who as he put it was
his match in in beauty and in brains and
see he actually was a business partner
with Ivana Trump and he put her in
charge of one of his casinos in Atlantic
City and later at the Plaza Hotel in New
York City he came to regret those
decisions he came to feel that there was
just too much competition going on
within the marriage he questioned her
management skills and decisions and he
resolved after that to have future
relationships be with women who would
not be a challenge to him or a
competition to him in business and
certainly his third wife Melania has a
very separate business life and is
really more of a homemaker than a
business person but Donald Trump's view
of women obviously very controversial a
number of people around the country see
him as insulting or offensive to women
he contends that he has promoted women
to the very top of his business
throughout his career and certainly at
least one of his executives was one of
the first women to run a major
construction project in New York City so
he has done that but as when it comes to
his wives he wants were traditional kind
of wife like his mother he says and yet
could you make the argument that his
daughter Ivanka very much in the same
mold as Donald Trump in terms of her own
business empire right well there's no
question that Donald Trump is very close
to his children and he takes great pride
in what they've done when we interviewed
Donald Trump in both occasions we were
in Trump Tower for interviews his
children came in we don't know if it was
something staged for our benefit or
there just happened to be there but you
could see you know there was closeness
there Ivanka came in and talked about
going to Florida and they have a golf
course and development down there and
she was going to talk about that so they
had a very nice conversation back and
forth that we were able to observe you
mentioned the marriages and it reminded
me in the book and you might have been
referring to this Steve on page 160 for
example we quote
Donald Trump talking about the day he
got married to Marla maples and he said
about this quote I was bored when she
was walking down the aisle I kept
thinking what the hell am I doing here
so in doing a biography we you know
we're not pontificate errs we are trying
to go in and write a full story that
tells the Donald Trump life and we've
looked as closely as we can at many
things that Donald Trump himself has
said over the years to fill in a lot of
gaps so that that kind of comment gives
you a little bit of insight into his
thinking he then divorced Marla and and
married Melania and by all accounts they
have a warm marriage and a young son but
that is part of the full story
understanding his relationship with
woman is part of understanding the story
of doctor dump interesting connection
between that attitude toward the
marriages and his attitude toward
politics and the presidency Donald Trump
told us that he is most fascinated he's
at his best when he's doing the hunt the
chase when he's wooing a woman or
running for president he said when he
gets things after that hunt and chase
he's not so interested anymore in that
by the way exchanges in Chapter nine of
the book our guest michael kranish and
mark fisher they are the co-authors of
the new Washington Post project Trump
revealed and will be covering the events
also next month as part of c-span two's
book TV programming Carole is joining us
from Salisbury North Carolina
good morning good morning it sounds like
a perfect person that we need for
president somebody to go out here and
say let's build something let's do
something instead of the trash that
we've had for eight years
the failed Obamacare the throw the
police under the bus why don't you write
a real nasty book about the eight years
of destruction that I as a 72 year old
out here have lived and I have lived and
I have seen the news every day on Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton and I want to
tell you she is absolutely the worst
person we ever need for president
Terrell thank you
the call Mark Fisher well we sent out
not to write a nasty book about anyone
we set out rather to write a book about
who Donald Trump is how his values and
principles were formed why he believes
what he does and so whether you think
he's the greatest thing since sliced
bread or a menace to society or
something in between I think what
American voters need and crave at this
stage is a full comprehensive look at
the life of this man you know Donald
Trump is the first person since Dwight
Eisenhower half a century ago to run for
president as a major party candidate
without previously having held elective
office and so he's not been vetted in
the same way that candidates generally
are you know generally politicians or
have lots written about their lives at
every stage in their career and that's
not happened with Donald Trump so that's
what we sought to do with this book
Michael from Naperville Illinois outside
of Chicago good morning good morning you
know I'm really disappointed in the
degradation of the quality of your
programming with these two fellows on
here I mean this is this is really
nonsense
what are they psychiatrist and trying to
do some psychoanalysis of Trump I'm
going to vote for Trump I voted for
Obama in 2008 one of the biggest con men
around so is Hillary Clinton with the
Clinton Foundation look at her husband
you know what do I care that he's been
divorced several times a nice looking
guy with big money is probably going to
do that half the country has been
divorced so this whole debate is
nonsensical these two guys wrote this
book to what make money and to a test
Trump that tried to influence the
election that's it in my opinion and I'm
really disappointed in c-span that
instead of talking about the issues the
fact that a lot of middle collects
people like myself are struggling you
bring on these tube fellows it's really
disappointing quite frankly well Michael
they are here at our invitation we are
talking about the book because it is a
newly released publication titled Trump
revealed looking at the full life of
Donald
Trump and of course it works because you
weigh in as well and share your calls
and comments and concerns and express
your point of view and that's what we're
all about so we thank you for the call
we'll give our guests a chance to
respond well sure you know appreciate
the call and and I understand the the
anger that's out there about what's
going on in the country that is
something that the Washington Post and
this was done by a team of reporters at
the Washington Post and we believe it's
a very even-handed job and the effort
here is to try to understand the rise of
Trump and certainly the stagnation of
the economy has has led to that in part
so when you're talking about a person
you might be President is very important
understand their personal character
their story writing a biography a full
biography helps you understand who the
person is and how they've done things in
the past so you could take a list of
campaign proposals and that's one thing
but she'd understand what they've done
throughout their life and that's what we
try to do in a biography and by the way
this weekend on c-span twos afterwards
part of book TV we sat down yesterday in
an interview with Ann Coulter who is a
syndicated columnist she's out with her
own book on Donald Trump and as part of
the afterword series she sat down with
tucker carlson who is the editor in
chief also a host on the Fox News
Channel
here's a portion of that conversation
that airs in its entirety this weekend
so if you were there so it sounds like
you're making argument that if you were
to narrow down what makes Trump so
loathsome to the people in power it's
his opposition to immigration and if you
were to narrow down what makes him so
appealing to others it's his opposition
immigration oh yes so this is about
immigration I think so I mean I love his
trade policies I love his no pointless
wars in the Middle East but I think
immigration is the great unifier do you
think that you'd mean even factoring in
the fact that you just wrote a book at
immigration and you have it on the mind
do you think there's there's evidence
that that's what this is really about
because you often hear people on
television said well the exit polls
don't don't tell us that right I don't
suggest immigration is number one on
people's priority list whenever they say
that I look at what people do say is
their number one issue and it's always
things like jobs terrorism right you
know cultural changes they're all
synonyms for immigration and also I mean
American
nice people I think they have the sense
especially with with the media telling
them this that if they say it's
immigration it's as if they're saying
something mean about immigrants and
they're nice people we like immigrants
and because Trump always says he loves
Hispanics that was my favorite tweet I
think the Hispanics but yeah that was my
all the things he's done other than the
Mexican rapists speech you like the taco
ball tweet oh my gosh that was so making
fun of multiculturalism and culture her
interview will air this weekend on
c-span twos book TV are afterwards
interview a chance for individuals to
sit down with leading authors and you
can check out the full schedule at
c-span org in a reaction to what she had
to say about her thoughts on Donald
Trump Marc Fisher well there are a lot
of books out there on the market that
are either pro or anti Donald Trump
rants and Ann Coulter's is is very much
a pro book what we tried to do in Trump
revealed is not take up side not make an
argument but rather look at the major
themes in a candidates life and I think
that's what's most useful to voters at
this stage you're choosing someone not
just because of their views on
immigration or other kinds of issues you
choosing someone based on how they make
decisions how they take in information
how they weigh what to do as president
and they there we talked to Donald Trump
about this how do you make decisions as
a president how do you how do you absorb
information and how do you pick which
side is right and what he told us is
that he doesn't like to read long
reports and briefings and the way a lot
of presidents do he prefers that people
come in talked to him for just 30
seconds a minute
tell him the merits or demerits of an
issue and then he'll make a decision
from his gut that's his preferred style
that's served him fairly well throughout
his career and he thinks he can bring
that to the White House and you
mentioned something that I thought our
audience would be interested in as we
were listening and Coulter and that is
the Obama voter in 2008 the Trump voter
in 2016 what did both of you learned
I was fascinated at going to Trump
rallies and talking to people and
learning about who they were and who
they supported in the past and what they
were looking for in a president
white a number of people kept telling me
that they had voted for Barack Obama in
2008 and now are supporting Donald Trump
and that's not something that springs to
mind as an obvious pattern but it it
kept popping up so I worked on a story
that was published in The Washington
Post a couple of weeks ago about the
Obama Trump voters and what they have in
common is they are the hope and change
voters they're the people who were drawn
in by Barack Obama's idea that he was
going to change Washington that he was
going to bring people together and that
that and the personal charisma that both
Barack Obama and Donald Trump brought to
their campaigns and a lot of those
people felt burned by the Obama
presidency and so they've turned to
Donald Trump again as a change agent and
some of them are regretful about their
votes for Barack Obama some of them say
hey these are both guys who wanted to
come from outside and change Washington
and that's what I really want because
they're frustrated with the paralysis
and so michael kranish leads to another
excerpt from the book you write the
following improbable did not begin to
describe what Donald Trump had achieved
angry outsiders had run for president
before it even collected a respectable
protest vote but now Donald Trump was
going to be crowned the Republican
nominee well you know over the years
well I've covered presidential politics
there have been third-party candidates
who have made a big impact they haven't
won the presidency but Ross Perot came
in and he was very impactful in the 92
race may have helped in that fact elect
Bill Clinton and any kind of Ralph Nader
in 2000 might have had enough votes away
from Al Gore to tip that boat to george
w bush so there is a strong element of p
of the country who wants a third party
or an outsider type candidate so Donald
Trump really was able to tap into that
same view we've had a reform party we've
had the tea party but there is no third
party right now we certainly do have the
libertarian candidate who could make an
impact in this race Donald Trump has
tried to take that role for himself but
within the Republican Party he's not a
natural fit he wants to be sort of a
independent third party person and you
saw him go back and forth over this but
he's within that party and I think
that's the reason you see some of the
tug and
whole within the party and his clashes
with Paul Ryan's speaker the house for
example so he's trying to walk that fine
line and right now as he goes to the
general he does want the base but he
also wants to go beyond that base and
win over the people who otherwise would
be inclined to vote for perhaps a third
party candidate this program is carried
live on c-span radio we welcome michael
kranish and mark fisher they are the
co-authors of trump revealed another
half hour in our conversation and Vicki
is joining us from st. Augustine Florida
good morning good morning first I'd like
to ask you what you think about the
blurred line between celebrity and
politics I bring to mind John Kennedy
for more than 50 years the Kennedy
family has been in our consciousness you
know they any of them passed away or had
failed life we still elevate them almost
to the point of a king or a queen
because they were attractive glamorous
Lex likes Trump and Melania you know
it's the same kind of thing what I want
to know as a voter are some of the
things that you've tried to explain in
your book I want to know the true values
that these politicians live by what this
past behavior was what they really
believe rather than what the media or
particularly television is trying to
show us Vicki thank you Mark Fisher
Vicki you asked a really important
question and and the whole question of
celebrity is one that Trump has thought
about for many years and in Trump
revealed we get into the whole evolution
of him as a showman he thinks of himself
as a showman it's not an insult or
something that we're laying on him this
is the way he describes himself and he
says that he went about creating this
kind of public character over many years
he can all recall seeing him on Saturday
Night Live or
doing WrestleMania events and there was
a rhyme and reason to that kind of
production of a public character where
he was trying to take his image as a
rich builder in New York City a bit of a
cartoon character the tabloid reports
about his
marriages and their breakups and he was
trying to transform that into something
that would have more appeal to
middle-class Americans that's why he
chose to do the reality TV show The
Apprentice where he thought this was a
way that he could kind of spread his
image and and alter it in ways that it
would be appealing to middle-class
voters middle-class Americans and it
would create this idea of Trump as a
brand that people were gone to and they
would see him as a tough decisive leader
and so the whole character that he used
and developed in The Apprentice was
designed to create this sense of someone
who was humane you know he became famous
for the line you're fired
but if you go back and look at those
shows he doesn't say that in a mean way
he actually shows some humility he
listens to his advisers he changes his
mind when his advisers have something
persuasive to say so he showed himself
as a decisive thoughtful leader in that
show and that kind of celebrity helped
him pave the way for this run Mark
Burnett the producer of The Apprentice
and before that survivor says that the
candidacy of Donald Trump would not have
been possible without the apprentice
let's go to Christian from Oklahoma City
good morning good morning I have three
comments please to the 72-hole ad that
talks about President Obama
why do you Republicans always forget
what Bush did before President Obama but
you guys just skipped that over secondly
how could these veterans vote for this
guy who had four or five deferments
because of bone spurs and he was still
playing sports and then he talked about
John McCain he didn't like John McCain
because he was a PLW and any veterans
vote for him this guy says there's a day
for you to go to Vietnam and get killed
or watch your brothers get killed but
i'ma stay up here and I may eat steak I
mean and use veterans back them up four
or five deferments that he didn't have
to go to just like Dick Cheney over bone
spurs and you Republicans eventually
backed this guy up who were the coward
who had five or four the firm
thank you to fit nan to die and for you
to watch her buddies die but did I sit
up here with your hats on y'all my
Vietnam vet you're voting for this guy
who couldn't give a damn about you guys
unbelievable unbelievable Thank You
Christian thank you for the call he was
from Oklahoma the the woman from North
Carolina you can sense the passion in
these voters right you know I've covered
different presidential candidates and I
remember covering the John Kerry
campaign and also co-authored a
biography about John Kerry and during
that campaign you had a lot of people
saying well yes he served in Vietnam but
he left early and there was criticism
here's a candidate who did serve and
they're people who will criticize that
so it sort of goes both ways what the
caller said about deferments Donald
Trump went to a military academy he he
did not volunteer to serve in the
military he did have bone spurs which
got him out of potential military
service so that's correct
the comments that Donald Trump made
about John McCain where he said I like
people who don't get captured as
prisoners of wars that's very very
controversial I think within both
parties and I think there's people on
all sides of the aisle who were shocked
at that in fact after he said that there
were stories written like well this
campaigns over someone who says
something like that he's not gonna make
it and his aides were surprised it was
not something that was planned ahead of
time so you know he's tried to walk
around that John McCain obviously
greatly at odds but they're both members
of the same party so this is the
position that the party finds itself
that the presidential nominee starts
attacking leaders of their own party and
in fact the prior presidential
Republican nominee that really has been
one of the incredible political stories
of this campaign season is whether
Donald Trump wins or loses the fact that
he got the nomination and to go back to
your earlier point that the rules don't
seem to apply to him and my question is
regardless of what happens in 2016 what
impact it may have in 2020 well I think
we've seen over the last several cycles
even before Donald Trump was on the
scene as a candidate a gradual but very
clear decline in the role of the parties
the trust that people have in the
parties the identification that people
have with the parties a number of
independents in the country continues to
rise and people have less and less of a
sense of ideologic
attachment or sense of a purity of
ideology and that's one of the reasons
Donald Trump has done so well this year
Donald Trump is allergic to ideology he
thinks that it's just not the way to
construct your view of the world he
believes in being the ultimate
pragmatist and he presents himself as a
deal maker who's willing to talk to
anyone who's willing to go in whatever
direction is necessary to get to the
bottom line and so that kind of anti
ideological approach is key I think to
his success this year from Las Vegas
Joey is next good morning yeah good
morning you know I can't understand how
this is even a race with Donald Trump
accomplished and if Donald Trump was
president when they brought that bill
about to dig the big dig at Boston I
wind up costing taxpayers twenty four
billion dollars and when they had that
fifty million dollar bridge to nowhere
in Alaska another Republican senator
that was another that was another God
that would have been Lance lost the desk
look at all the money I saved in two
seconds you understand these people's
all know what they're doing it's just
it's just said it said this man hired
millions of people wouldn't how many
people didn't Clinton hire he has
thousands and tens of thousands of
people on a payroll right now and how
many hundreds of thousands of blacks is
hired in there's life tell we will get a
response thank you
mark this year well it's interesting you
mentioned the Big Dig and other kinds of
the government excess Donald Trump that
really came to the attention of many
people in New York City originally back
in the early 1980s when he kind of came
in to save the day the New York City
government had failed repeatedly and had
spent millions of dollars trying to
repair an ice-skating rink in Central
Park and the ice skating rink called
Wollman Rink was just a thorn in the
side of then Mayor Ed Koch and his
administration and Donald Trump came
forward and present
to the public a plan where he would pay
for and fix this ice-skating rink in
record time under budget or else he
would cover the whole cost and in fact
he came through and he built it in a
matter of weeks and he did it for way
less than even he had initially said he
would and this was a roaring success he
embarrassed the mayor and he came to
become kind of a folk hero to a lot of
people in New York City as a result of
that so he he's very much someone who
believes that he can cut through the
bureaucracy and the red tape and get
things done in a big way as far as
employees yes he's had many thousands of
employees over the years but one of the
things we show and Trump revealed is
that a lot of times when he's been in
financial trouble and he's had six
corporate bankruptcies the people who
lose out are the employees the vendors
the contractors the small business
people who end up being stiffed while he
gets the money that was coming to him
and that's been a recurrent theme I
think one of the points also that the
caller was making was the government
spending that seemed to be that the the
main problem of course Donald Trump is
Marcos talking about he came to power in
a way because he was able to get tens of
millions of dollars in tax breaks from
New York City this was a key element of
his strategy at the beginning so Trump
himself has certainly benefited from
things that the government has granted
him and he has talked about the need to
rebuild infrastructure this cost money
it's one of the main things he wants to
do I don't know if he said specifically
here's how I'm gonna take the money from
X to Y that hasn't been laid out
entirely but to do the infrastructure
rebuilding he was talking about would be
very very expensive calling Jeb Bush
sleepy and tired a little Marco Rubio
lyin Ted and now in the general election
going after Hillary Clinton and calling
her corrupt and a bigot I want to share
with you this is a interview that took
place with Rachel Maddow on the program
last night we can have that ready to go
it's it's an interview that was
conducted and it was the issue of
Hillary Clinton's health and he's been
making a lot of charges as to whether or
not she is healthy or not and there's
others who have been saying the same
thing Rudy Giuliani who's also
questioning the health of Hillary
Clinton why does he go about this
approach well he
to think of himself as a provocateur he
likes to think of himself as someone who
understands what the emotional perhaps
insecurities of the voters might be and
he likes to tap into that and win a big
reaction so he is someone who uses a lot
of course language he uses a lot of
inflammatory language and he sees
himself as kind of a tabloid character
in that way he learned back in the 1970s
and 80s when he was on the front pages
of New York City's tabloid newspapers
every day that the way to get that kind
of attention was to be inflammatory to
be provocative and so he sees that as a
way to get attention and to build his
brand you know he was an early and very
vocal supporter of the idea the birther
movement the idea that President Obama
was born not in this country but but in
Africa and he in his typical fashion
Trump really would not back off from
that he's always believed that you don't
explain you don't apologize you just
push forward and so this is last night
Kellyanne Conway on MSNBC interviewed by
Rachel Maddow Laurie Clinton released a
normal doctor statement what we've got
from Donald Trump that real that letter
really is absurd and we've actually
contacted the doctor who wrote it to try
to get some background turns out he was
using a medical credential on his name
then he's no longer entitled to you it's
like there's a lot of really not
upstanding things about what we know
there and so I mean for one wise why is
a gastroenterologist is a digestive
specialist why is Donald Trump in seeing
a gastroenterologist for 35 years oh
then I don't know for sure I think I
just learned in the last week Rachel I
promise like can't ask your ask the
campaign manager can I please make a
request to you that we get a more a more
substantial I have a constantly
requested I assure you that he does have
doctor he has doctors in positions and I
want to also add one more thing I was
told by a different anchor last night in
a different network that Hillary's
doctors had the least part of her
medical information her health history
and that she has she's in good health
and I said great because I want her to
be in excellent health in other words
that's just not I think stamina is
different than health you know bigger on
the campaign trail but I look at Hillary
Clinton not
they're more as a strategy it's got its
scarcity as a strategy it's that we
don't want to put her out there because
when we do people are reminded that she
doesn't meet the 70% of Americans who
want a change election in new direction
she is the person who has earned a
majority of Americans Rachel saying I
dislike her and I distrust her well I
can't imagine what comes after the but
what do you mean but but I think I'll
vote for I think I'll give it a whirl
michael kranish as you listen to that
there is that seed of doubt that the
Trump campaign Rudy Giuliani Donald
Trump has done on Hillary Clinton's
health and he's done it as your
colleague mark Fisher has said on other
areas in other areas well first of all
what was asked there was certainly
correct asked for and that is a full
medical record from Donald Trump so that
has not been released his tax returns
not been released so as journalists
certainly we also push that would you
release all these records when those
kind of questions are asked and you
don't want to just let it lay there I
certainly a campaign will then push back
and say well what about you and turn the
focus right away to the other side so
they're trying to raise those doubts and
a lot of times the campaign is a daily
effort to throw things against the wall
see what sticks see what picks up
traction with a certain group of voters
and this is certainly gotten a lot of
play the fact that we're talking about
it it shows that it continues to get a
little play Hillary Clinton has released
more detailed records on there her
medical background and Donald Trump has
so far she's also released her tax
returns so they're going to try to then
turn it back and say okay we've done
this you know where's your records and
you can see this building up to a
crescendo that will come in the debate
where the candidates will directly
challenge each other and Hillary Clinton
presumably will say if it hasn't been
done you know where your tax returns I
have at least mine and so you'll see
this become a focal point as we move on
here from Forney Texas rachel is next
independent line good morning yes excuse
me I'm not really going to vote for
either one of these people that's
running I'm so upset with what we have
to go far and you know we have a
generation that cut their teeth on talk
radio radio and cable news of hate and
anger and this is how we wind up with
the people we have running today and you
know Donald Trump once said that if he
was to ever run for president he would
run
Republican because they were stupid
people and he would win and then we got
Hillary if she's the one who first
started this birther issue with the
president President Obama and she found
out there was nothing to it so she
handed it off to the Republicans and
they pounded it and pounded it until
people started believing it and there
there was nothing to it
and there's still people that believe
that his mother went to Kenya or
whatever and had him and he's not
citizen they could go back where he was
going to school his education and find
out he's been here all these years and
he has a birth announcement he was born
in Hawaii and it was the hospital but
that put that out but they're still
arguing and they still hope that there's
some stupid people that will hold on to
this and believe it and it's upsetting
that you don't want another 20 years we
might have some some I mean we've got
some crazies running today well it's
what's clear about this campaign and
unfortunate is that both of these
candidates are deeply unpopular and it's
hard to think of another race that we've
had in this country where the two major
party candidates were as unpopular as
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump are
that said there are obviously enormous
differences between them both in terms
of policy and in terms of their
personality background the way they make
decisions the way they think about power
and so people are being forced across
the country to overcome their antipathy
or doubts about these candidates and
make a choice based on those other
factors who are they where do they come
from what are their true beliefs in
Hillary Clinton we have someone who has
a very clear set of principles and
values and positions on issues that
she's laid out some would say in
excruciating detail without the kind of
display of her personality and her
emotions and and those kinds of
emotional values that people might want
to know about a president in Donald
Trump we have someone who's vaguer on
policy but is
kind of all out there as a personality
and so what we try to do in Trump
revealed is is give you a sense both
from his own voice from our interviews
with Donald Trump and from interviews
with literally hundreds of people around
him family classmates neighbors from his
childhood as well as all the way up to
today of who this man is how does he
make decisions why is he running for
president and so whether you like him or
hate him or just can't figure him out I
think what you'll find in the book is a
sense of where he came from and why he's
running and what makes him tick
and to that point Evan Thomas michael
kranish who's the author of being Nixon
had this review in the Washington Post a
portrait of a comical chilling and
somewhat sad Donald Trump there's this
from USA Today a new bio reveals a
troubling portrait of Donald Trump by
Ray Locker and from James Perry at your
former employee of the Boston Globe the
new Trump biography offers a complex
look at the man who would be President
well those are all very I think fair
reviews because we really are trying to
provide a full fair portrait of a very
complicated figure this is a man who you
know he didn't like a lot of members of
Congress and other people who run for
the presidency over the the country's
history you know they're not a straight
line they are a series of contradictions
as they figure out where they stand on
various issues you know you can go back
to the very founding of this country and
you look at the people who have run for
president and they are also in their own
way complex figures I think of you know
Thomas Jefferson who wrote that all men
are created equal
yet he owned slaves so you can go back
to the almost the very beginning in
George Washington and say we you have to
understand that these are all
complicated figures they're oftentimes
you you try to understand how do they
come to these conclusions and right now
what we see with Tom Trump is a man who
was pivoted throughout his life changed
party registration
seven times trains positions many times
and he talked last week about not
wanting to pivot because he is who he is
but then he said this week that he might
soften his stance on immigration so that
sounds like it is a pivot so even now in
the course of a few days it sounds like
he is once again doing what he does a
lot of and that is trying to figure out
in fact you know where he does stand and
what will help him get elected is this
your
photograph from the cover of the book I
know this is a photograph that we got
from a photo agency let's go to Marsha
joining us from Mechanicsburg
Pennsylvania good morning good morning
right Marsha yes I'm definitely going to
read the book I'm interested in finding
out who is the real Donald Trump like
most of your viewers and even your dad's
have mentioned he's pivoting back and
forth on different issues and I'm hoping
that this book will give him some type
of character unfortunately right now I
can only I mean he's a promoter more
than anything as far as I see so far and
I'm he you know he serves the pot and
the only sugar I could think of
unfortunately is our bond King when he
you know boxing boxing well he was a
promoter and you know he do have a
certified part of the media who by the
way was at the Republican convention in
Cleveland and it's interesting you
mentioned Don King because we were in
one of our visits with Donald Trump we
brought up this whole question of the
allegations that he is either fomenting
racism across the country or has said
things that are racially offensive and I
put this to mr. Trump I told him about a
cab ride I had in which the taxi driver
said you know I agree with Trump on a
lot of things and I would support him
but it seems like he's against people
for who they are racially or ethnically
and I put this to mr. Charlie said
what's what's your reaction to this how
would you decide that you're racist and
Trump said I'm the least racist person
in the world and he took out a newspaper
for that dunk that Don King the boxing
promoter publishes in Ohio in which Don
King supported Donald Trump and this was
his idea of how to defend himself
against this charge of racial bias was
to cite some of the celebrities who he's
worked with through the years and who
are supportive of him there is this
whole question of racial insensitivity
that really boils down to Donald Trump
being very much in the world view of the
period in which he grew up in the 1950s
and 60s and the language that he uses
about race tends to be from that era and
it tends to clang a little off to some
people today given the ways in which the
society has changed but he thinks of
himself as as he put at the least racist
person in the world michael kranish
Donald Trump has made the reference to
Margaret Thatcher as a precursor to the
election of Ronald Reagan back in 1980
she and the Conservatives winning in
1979 and Nigel Farage at an event in
Jackson Mississippi last night drawing
the analogy to the brexit vote earlier
this year as an anti-establishment vote
let's watch what he said and get your
reaction if I was an American citizen I
wouldn't vote for Hillary Clinton if you
paid me
in fact I wouldn't vote for Hillary
Clinton if she paid me
folks the message is clear the parallels
are there there are millions of ordinary
Americans who've been let down who've
had a bad time who feel the political
class in Washington are detached from
them who feel so many of their
representatives are politically crack
parts of that liberal media elite they
feel people aren't standing up for them
and they've actually in many cases given
up on the whole electoral process and I
think I think that you have a fantastic
opportunity here with this campaign you
can go out you can beat the pollsters
you can beat the commentators you can
beat Washington
and you'll do it by doing what we did
for brexit in britain we had our own
people's army of ordinary citizens who
went out and delivered leaflets who went
to meet people where they work and where
they socialized who convinced and
inspired people to go out if this was
the one and only time in their life and
to vote for change so my advice to you
if you want change in this country you
better get your walking boots on you
better get out there campaigning and
remember and remember anything is
possible if enough decent people are
prepared to stand up against the
establishment Nigel Faraj made his
comments in Jackson Mississippi by the
way that speech is available on our
website at c-span org he of course was
behind the brexit vote from the UK
Independence Party the former leader of
that party silliman go back to michael
kranish and ask you whether or not there
are in fact any parallels between what
Great Britain went through and what
we're seeing here in the u.s. well see
the most powerful word in politics has
changed and in both countries there is
this economic anxiety so the parallel is
that people have looked at what's going
on and said my situation has not
improved my wages have been stagnant for
years what is the problem and
politicians for a number of years have
been trying to come up with solutions in
Washington the city's obviously is
broken Congress is not getting a lot
done and there's a very low approval of
Congress and also of the presidency so
there is that parallel we don't we're
not withdrawing from something so it's
different in the terms of Briggs at
versus the United States but there is
that same sense of anxiety and what is
the answer to that so oftentimes when
there's this feeling that a you want
change and that there's this great
economic anxiety and how did we change
things first you hear a messenger it
doesn't necessarily mean that that
person has all the solutions but they
they're hearing the message and this
person is different and so if you're
looking at this campaign and saying well
Hillary Clinton it's a Clinton we've had
Clinton's before it sounds similar
they don't want some entire break from
the past so there's an appeal out there
that certainly Donald Trump tapped into
in the primaries and he's trying to do
again so in the general election and
it's a that's a powerful message
talking about change the question is
what specifically would you do globalism
is a big issue how exactly he says I'll
tear up trade deals they're gonna be
those who then argue well if you do that
it might be worse for jobs others who
will say be better and then you get to
definer points but the message itself of
change to try to do something about the
economic society is a powerful one and
has been in both countries John good
morning from Jonesboro Georgia yes good
wine I have a question for mark
and Michael if mark is the editor and
Michael is the investigative political
reporter I would like to know how many
articles they have ran on the Hillary
Clinton email scandal also on the
Hillary Clinton Foundation also on the
Arkansas land bill and the uranium deal
that was struck with Russia thank you
for the call we'll get a response that's
a great question and in fact the
Washington Post has led the way in
reporting on the Clinton Foundation and
on the email scandal and we've done
extremely in-depth articles throughout
the preceding months in fact going back
more than a year about both of those
issues and other aspects of the Clinton
campaign raising very important
questions about her candidacy about
these issues of honesty and authenticity
that surround her campaign similarly
what we've done with Donald Trump in
both a series in the Washington Post and
in this book Trump revealed is to take a
rigorous serious biographical look at
Donald Trump very similarly we're doing
the same kind of project with Hillary
Clinton in which a long series of
stories is unfolding in the Washington
Post and available on Washington Post
calm for you to read and so we take very
much the same approach with both
candidates as we do every four years and
let me ask you about the influence his
family had on Donald Trump's decision to
run how significant was that well the
story is told that Donald Trump has
certainly talked about running for
president back since 1980 there been
questions about will you run for
president and every four years he's sort
of stepped up looked at it in 2000 he
actually talked with a Reform Party he
was on the ballot in two states as a
Reform Party Canada
president before he said this is not
going to work out I don't want to run
and then lose and the story is told that
Melania said look if you are going to
keep on talking about this you just do
it now is the time if you're not going
to do it then stop talking about it so
he looked at the field and he decided
that he should finally run and so he is
but the family you know is a very
important to him but I think they
probably told him that you know you can
do this if you're going to do it now is
the time and Mark Fisher let me conclude
with this question to you was there an
aha moment boy that's interesting a real
surprise as you sat down and talked to
Donald Trump and researched this book
you know there was an interesting moment
one of our visits with Donald Trump
where before we even sat down to begin
the interview he said boys come with me
and he took us across the hall to a
conference room where there was a large
table even bigger than this one here and
it was filled every inch of it with
stacks of magazines and on the cover of
every magazine was Donald Trump and what
he said to us as we walked into the room
was look at what I just found as if he
didn't even know that this room was
immediately outside his office filled
with magazines with himself on the cover
he took us on a tour of the of the
covers and it was kind of an odd moment
to have this man who's the Republican
nominee for president to be so
enraptured with his own image on these
covers it was a very revealing moment I
thought about the role that ego plays in
his life and his his sense of self it
was at once fascinating and disturbing
an American journey of ambition ego
money empower the book is titled Trump
revealed our conversation with michael
kranish and Mark Fisher the co-authors
of this Washington Post book project
gentlemen thank you very much for being
with us we appreciate it
thank you Steve thank you Steve